bienvenidos de nuevo ha debido haber
borrado esto antes de empezar el vídeo
pero bueno espero que no nos quiten
mucho tiempo ya está bienvenidos de
nuevo perdón por quitarte un poquito de
tiempo pero ahora sí vamos a trabajar en
el siguiente problema que es el problema
número 6 y dice tenemos una figura que
está a escala muchas veces las figuras
están en escala y hay veces que te dicen
que las figuras no están a escala sin
embargo la mayoría de las veces está en
escala y creo que esto es por obvias
razones y tenemos una figura más o menos
así la cual está muy fácil de dibujar es
una cosa así una cosa por acá y después
de aquí mismo tenemos otra recta
y me dicen que en esta figura este
ángulo este de aquí ni de 3x mientras
que este de aquí 3x grados podríamos
decir mientras que este de aquí me de 2x
grados y por último este de aquí este
mide 4x grados y que me dice el problema
en la figura siguiente tenemos la
intersección de tres rectas en un mismo
punto formando así tres ángulos
estos tres cuanto vale x bueno
esencialmente lo que hay que hacer es
fijarnos que este ángulo este de aquí si
nosotros le sumamos este de aquí este de
aquí y por último le sumamos este de
aquí entonces nos da una circunferencia
entera es decir que 2x grados más 3x
grados más 4x grados dan una vuelta
entera al círculo y cuántos grados tiene
un círculo
360 esto es igual a 360 grados o dicho
de otra manera 2 x 3 x 4 x esto es lo
mismo que 9 x 9 x es igual a 360 y ahora
si divido ambos lados entre 9 ya están
tengo la solución de este problema
dividiendo entre 9 este y este se va y
me queda que x es igual a 360 entre 9 36
entre 9 es lo mismo que 44 y después
bajamos el 0 40 grados bueno
otro problema bastante sencillito que
por cierto es el inciso cm y bueno nos
da tiempo de hacer el siguiente problema
ya está problema número 7 y dice x y y z
son enteros son enteros tales que
cumplen las siguientes ecuaciones que x
elevado a la menos un medio esto es
igual a
tercio a un tercio esta es la primera
ecuación la segunda ecuación es que
james elevado a la zeta
esto es igual a 16 y me dicen que z
tiene que ser más grande que yo y bueno
lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale x más
z cuando vale x maceta y cómo resolvemos
esto creo que la clave de este problema
es fijarnos en que x y y z son enteros x
y z son enteros es el primer dato que me
dan son enteros esto es muy importante y
nos va a servir bastante porque bueno si
nosotros observamos la primera ecuación
de aquí como podemos obtener el valor de
x bueno esta ecuación tenemos x elevado
a la menos un medio es igual a un tercio
pero recordando propiedades de los
exponentes esto es lo mismo que poner
uno entre x elevado a un medio esto es
igual a un tercio y bueno recuerda que x
elevado a la un medio es exactamente lo
mismo que la raíz cuadrada de x esto
está en las leyes de los exponentes
entonces 1 entre la raíz cuadrada de x
esto es igual a un tercio y de aquí se
nota que la raíz cuadrada de x tiene que
ser igual a 3 la raíz cuadrada de x esto
tiene que ser igual a 3 y entonces x
tiene que ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 9 estrés por lo
tanto x tiene que tomar el valor de 9 y
ya está
ya tenemos de aquí x ahora xe se enteró
vamos bien hasta ahí pero la siguiente
ecuación es la que causa ruido dice que
he elevado a la z esto es igual a 16 y
elevado a la z esto es igual a 16 y aquí
la clave es pensar que tenemos números
enteros que el número entero elevado a
la z me da 16 bueno se te podría ocurrir
primero 4 elevado al cuadrado esto es
igual a 16 o también podrás pensar en 16
elevado a la 1
esto también es 16 o tal vez 2 elevado a
la 4
esto también es 16 aquí tenemos nuestras
tres posibles soluciones de estos
números que sean enteros pero además me
dan otra clave me dicen que z tiene que
ser más grande que yo
z valdría 2 y lleva al día 4 y por eso
esto no se puede z sería más chico que
james en este caso z valdría 1 lleva al
día 16 y entonces ya sería más grande
que z y nos lo que queremos y en este
caso se trata de 4 llévale 2 y 4 es más
grande que 2 por lo tanto esta es la
opción correcta es decir que z va a
valer 4 y que va a valer 2 ya tenemos el
valor de z ya tenemos el valor de james
ya tenemos el valor de x todos son
enteros
además z es más grande que yo y se
cumplen estas ecuaciones y ahora sí
cuánto es x + z x z es 94 lo cual es 13
13 es la solución de este ejercicio lo
cual es el inciso de y ya está un
problema menos así que vámonos el
siguiente el problema número 8 que tiene
una gráfica muy parecida a ésta
problema número 8 y déjame hacerte la
gráfica que ellos están haciendo me
entonces déjame poner algo así no sé si
sea relevante en el problema pero al
menos la hacemos me queda un eje por
aquí tengo otro eje por acá muy bien
este de aquí es mi eje de leyes este es
mi eje x hasta aquí vamos todo en orden
tenemos por aquí el 2 el 2 en x tenemos
por aquí el 4 tenemos por aquí el 6
tenemos por aquí el 8 y después tenemos
una semi circunferencia así que déjame
ver si puedo hacer esta
semicircunferencia por aquí tengo una
circunferencia parecida a ésta
no me quedo tan exacto pero se ve más o
menos así
suponte que este es el 8 que aquí toca
perfectamente al 8 más vamos a ponerlo
todo acá perfectamente aquí al 8 está
aquí mi número 8 no es este y esta
circunferencia tiene como centro el
punto 40 por cierto es una semi
circunferencia solamente nos vamos a
fijar en la parte de arriba de esta
circunferencia mientras que la parte de
abajo no existe
imagínate que no está o mejor para que
no te confundas vamos a borrar la de una
manera muy rápida para que así no
pienses en esta parte de abajo solamente
nos vamos a concentrar en la parte de
arriba y la parte de arriba que me dice
bueno me dicen que si esta
circunferencia su centro está en el 40 y
además toca el punto 80 es decir pasa
también por este punto y por el origen
entonces lo que me preguntan es lo
siguiente
cuál de las siguientes opciones son
coordenadas en x son coordenadas en x de
dos puntos en el semicírculo en este es
el círculo cuyas coordenadas en ye sean
iguales es decir me van a dar dos
coordenadas en x y yo lo que quiero ver
es que sus coordenadas en 10 sean
iguales como está eso pues bueno puedes
visualizar que por ejemplo si yo tengo
dos puntos aquí mira tomemos esta
herramienta y este de aquí y si yo te
hago una línea recta por acá entonces
esta línea recta va a tocar en dos
puntos a esta circunstancia va a tocar
en este punto y en este punto sin
embargo como la línea es paralela al eje
de las x entonces estos dos puntos
tienen la misma distancia en eso es a lo
que se refiere otro ejemplo si yo me
tomo otra recta por aquí vamos a
tomarnos este de aquí ésta cruza a estas
en una circunferencia en dos puntos
en este punto de aquí bien
punto de camps los cuales están en la
misma distancia en bien por lo tanto
estoy encontrando dos coordenadas en x
que tienen la misma altura en yemen y
esto es porque la circunferencia tiene
una propiedad muy importante si te das
cuenta esta circunstancia que si la
cortamos por aquí desde su centro
entonces lo que pasa de un lado va a
pasar del otro y bueno no solamente esta
circunferencia sino todas las
circunferencias tienen un eje de
simetría esta circunferencia es
simétrica si la cortamos por aquí lo que
pasa de este lado va a pasar exactamente
igual de este otro lado es simétrica
bajo este corte que le estoy haciendo
por lo tanto si no encuentro un punto
aquí que tenga una cierta altura en
james me voy a encontrar otro mismo
punto aquí que tenga la misma altura y
ahora antes de ponerte aquí los puntos
quiero que te des cuenta de algo muy
importante como esta circunferencia es
simétrica bajo este corte que estoy
haciendo entonces si yo me encuentro
aquí este punto la distancia que hay de
aquí
este punto a esta coordenada en x va a
ser exactamente la misma a la distancia
que va a ver de aquí hasta este otro
punto hasta la otra coordenada en x como
este es el punto medio o mi eje de
simetría tiene que cumplir que la misma
distancia se cumple para ambos por
ejemplo aquí en este caso de este punto
de ver de la misma distancia que tomo de
aquí hasta acá hasta que llegó al punto
de verde va a ser exactamente la misma
que la distancia que me voy a tomar de
aquí hasta acá y eso es porque recuerda
que lo que pasa de un lado va a pasar
del otro lado entonces puedo subir este
por acá puedo subir este por acá o
podemos subir estos por acá y aquí está
la clave de este problema si en lugar de
pensar en la ecuación de este círculo
fijarnos qué es lo que pasa con la
coordenada en lleida cada uno de los
puntos que me dan me fijo en que la
distancia al punto 40 sea la misma si la
distancia de dos puntos que estén aquí
es la misma al punto 4,0 entonces
podemos asegurar que tienen la misma
altura en el eje de las vías
así que fíjate bien lo que queremos es
que tengan la misma distancia que sean
equidistantes al punto x igual a 4 y el
primer inciso me dan dos valores en x el
valor de 1 y el valor de 6 y si te das
cuenta
aquí ya no cumple porque uno está a una
distancia de tres unidades de cuatro a
tres unidades de 4 mientras que 6 está a
una distancia de dos unidades de 4 por
lo tanto no tienen la misma distancia al
punto x igual a 4 y porque no tienen la
misma instancia estoy segurísimo que
esto no va a tener la misma altura en
yemen recuerda que lo que pasa en un
lado tiene que pasar del otro y si
nosotros nos acercamos por acá tres
unidades estaríamos por aquí mientras
que en el 6 estaríamos por acá pues las
alturas son distintas vamos a ver qué es
lo que pasa con el inciso b me da el
valor de 1
y de oro
uno está a tres unidades de cuatro está
en tres unidades de cuatro mientras que
ocho está a cuatro unidades de cuatro
por lo tanto no tienen la misma
distancia al cuatro importa tanto no van
a tener la misma altura en james uno
está aquí tenemos esta altura mientras
que 8 está justo aquí es decir ni
siquiera tenemos altura por lo tanto
estos tampoco son mi respuesta vamos a
ver qué pasa con elipsis o se es 2 y 6 2
está a una distancia de 4 de 2 unidades
y 6 está una distancia de 4 de 2
unidades
perfecto esto sí funcionan como tienen
la misma distancia a x igual a 42 está
por aquí 6 está por aquí y por lo tanto
los dos van a tener la misma altura ya
están tenemos de respuesta el inciso 6 y
de hecho a los demás incisos te puedes
dar cuenta que no tienen la misma altura
porque no tienen la misma distancia así
que vamos a ver el siguiente problema el
problema número
y creo que con ese problema voy a
finalizar este vídeo así que vamos con
todo al problema número 9 y qué me dice
dice si p es un entero p es entero y
además 3 es el residuo 3 es el residuo
residuo de dividir 2 p 7 entre 5 de 2 p
+ 7 entre 5 lo que me preguntan es cuál
es uno de los posibles valores que puede
tomar p y bueno vamos a recordar un poco
la divisibilidad entre 5 y esto se puede
hacer de muchas maneras sin embargo creo
que es la opción más fácil es tomarnos
cada uno de los incisos y probar para
que te des cuenta que obtenemos un
residuo de 3 ahora si nosotros tenemos
números divisibles entre 5 exactamente
estos números se ven de la forma 5
15 20 25 es decir terminan en 5 o en 0
todo el número que termina el 5 en 0 es
divisible entre 5 sin embargo si yo
quiero pensar en los números que dejan
residuo 3 al dividirlos entre 5 pues
habría que sumarle 3 a estos es decir me
quedaría 8 13 18 23 28 33 38 y viste el
patrón tienen que acabar o en 8 o en 3
cualquier número que acabe en 8 en 3 al
dividirlo entre 5 me va a dar un residuo
de 3 sea cual sea así que si nos fijamos
en cada uno de los incisos en los cuales
me van a dar valores de pe enteros y yo
los pongo aquí arriba en el numerador
cuando obtenga un número que acabe en 8
que caben 3 de manera muy segura podemos
decir que su residuo va a ser 3 porque
cualquier número que acaba en 8 o en 3
al dividirlo entre 5 tiene un residuo de
3 así que vamos a probarlos el insisto
me dice
qué p es igual a 22 por 2 es 47 esto me
da 11 y aquí ya no funcionó porque 11 no
es un número que se parezca a estos no
es número que acaban en 3 ni en otro así
que vamos a ver el inciso b el inciso b
dice p igual a 3 3 x 2 667 es 12-13
perfecto cuando p vale 3 obtengo 13 en
el numerador 6 + 7 es 13 y este sí es un
número que acaba en 3 por lo tanto al
dividirlo entre 5 me va a dar de residuo
3 y lo podemos ver desde aquí 13 entre 5
cabe dos veces y sobran 3 y ya está no
tenemos que pensar más en los demás
incisos porque mi respuesta es el inciso
b así que ya tengo este problema número
9 qué bueno que no tuvimos que ver todos
los demás incisos para que así nos
podamos ver mejor en el siguiente vídeo
en el siguiente vídeo le seguimos a
estos problemas